now you've been very busy i was looking
at your imdb page and you have a lot of
things in
post and pre how do you keep yourself
looking so beautiful and composed
in the sort of jackie oh way and and and
rushing around i'm sure you have so much
on your plate what can you advise
another la actor
on sort of just keeping level headed
because it's
easy in the city to to get you know sort
of pulled in many directions oh
definitely
it really is i i think it's valuing your
private life valuing your life at home
and taking that time for yourself every
day even if it's just in the morning
wake up a little bit earlier and
if it's your if exercising makes you
feel good do that if going on for a hike
makes you feel good do that but spending
time with your family your friends like
take that time
it's so important to get time for
yourself because if not
you're constantly in this wheel of
working and you're traveling and you're
with people
and talking about yourself all day it's
just it can get
to be very consuming and self-involved
and if you don't take that time to
do something that makes you feel good uh
it can be really quite a downfall i
think yeah
i don't like that otherwise i like the
hype part that's good yeah what about
for you
yeah i agree things that make you stay
grounded
i just took a trip to new york just to
like be with my family for the super
bowl and my brother and i caught a ufc
fight
like um hobbies are important like this
isn't all we do this is
all we do right now to make money and
for a living and it's what we love to do
but you know i like to play tennis or
sit on my couch and
watch the bachelor with my girlfriend
like that's a fun thing for me to do
eat food i don't know yeah yeah eating
foods great yeah